[Music]
coming back to the statistics you
mentioned in your opening you
suggested that there was these are
involved very complicated calculations
but why is there so little correlation
between the amount we throw at something
and the results we see longevity
quality of life
i mean what why is that
the biggest driver is inequalities so
basically if you come from glasgow if
you live in one part of glasgow and
you're a man you're you're going to live
15 years longer than in another part of
glasgow neighborhoods that are very
close to one another irrespective of
your experience of health care although
even then you might be less likely to be
diagnosed early with cancer get the
treatment you need if you can't argue
your case or don't have relatives who
can do that for you so these things are
all intertwined so those are actually
the biggest determinants of life
expectancy in developed countries the
exception is if you live in an
environment where you don't have access
to basic public health and health care
of course your life expectancy is
affected so know how no matter how much
money we spend on health care in the uk
unless we can improve people's lives
we're actually just flushing it down the
toilet because the demand will always be
there yeah and also i think completely
agree but also there are
you know there are less tangible things
so for example we know that um
loneliness versus being part of
communities and being connected with
other people is really deleterious to
longevity um and linda you mentioned
about access to healthcare you know if
you if you're brought up in fortunate
circumstances with parents and teachers
who really believe in you you have lots
of opportunities you take them you get
them you feel much more empowered and
confident and you're much more likely to
you know
when you're not being offered healthcare
or you're being fobbed off in some way
or you don't want to you don't you don't
want to bother you know these busy
doctors etc you know you're less likely
to access the kind of care that would be
helpful to you in the long run so you're
saying that upbringing is crucial or
they're brought up to
operate and also the communities in
which you live in the kind of subtle
messages in society that make you feel
confident i can be anyone i can do
anything or the kind of experience in
society where people get knockbacks you
know often through no fault of their own
look at what happened over the last
couple of years some people happen to be
in the wrong jobs and you know had had a
bad time so you know what really is
needed as a society and as a government
who has this overarching kind of view
about human beings the conditions they
live in what people's needs are and that
drives things going forward that's a
fascinating face the subtle messages we
give to society i mean you guys are in
this business i mean what are these
subtle messages that we need to
give more of or or as it were you know
put into out the minds of our children
and our news media and our governments
most important well the most important
thing we can give children is love i
mean in the work that we're doing in
scotland looking at we have something
called the promise which is uh children
who have been in the care system or at
risk of the care system so their life
chances both their health and their
well-being are dramatically affected by
not being loved in the same way as
others so i think giving people support
love and then moving on giving people
good information remains important but
having the confidence as susan says to
interact so these are soft things that
we can do and you know people who are
trained in mental health engage with
people and that's why you were talking
about counseling therapies they're
looking for the listening and also the
tools to think about how they engage
with others so those those are things
which do cost money but they're not as
expensive as some of the other things
and in addition to love i think another
thing that again studies show this is
something called self-efficacy so sorry
about the jargon but it's basically
um
showing that people can make a
difference to the world around them you
know feeling efficacious and what's been
shown to happen if you could improve
people's feeling of empowerment i
suppose
that predicts you know getting jobs the
amount of money you earn lots of things
much more than other more kind of um
objective measures so so you know in
addition to giving love i think
really
encouraging children and adolescents and
adults
to
really think that what they can do can
make a difference but you do have to
have a society around you where that's
true of yeah can i pick up on that point
because that's an important one and i
think
the caveat at the end was really
important susan i agree with that
because we want to avoid phony
empowerment as well the idea that if you
if you just work hard enough and you
believe in yourself hard enough things
will
turn out good for you in the end and i
think the the lifestyle mantra falls
into this trap to some extent it's
change your lifestyle and things will
get better well what's that saying to
someone the onus is on you to change
your predicament but what happens if
you're a single mom
living in a council estate you've got
three kids living in a council state in
in south london
you know you're struggling you're
stressed
you're not going to be able to change
your lifestyle it's hard to change your
lifestyle when you're living in poverty
in social deprivation you're suffering
from discrimination and i think as a
society we shouldn't be selling the
illusion that self-empowerment is enough
it's not enough we need socially
uh we need mentally healthy social
policy
we need political critique of the
policies that are generating
poor mental health and physical health
in the population and we shouldn't
acquit
our government of the responsibility for
addressing those issues by locating the
cause of the problem in self-empowerment
and stuff
so i'm going to go back to overweight
and obesity you know we've just come out
of a pandemic and our prime minister who
discovered that have carrying extra
weight might have been a factor for him
in his covert outcomes was committed to
doing something about childhood obesity
and i told you about the politicians
only thinking about the short term one
of the things we could do about that is
actually not blame kids for becoming
overweight or obese not blame their
parents for not cooking them healthy
meals that they can't afford but
actually do something about
where our food is coming from what's in
our food what's cheap what's expensive
and the marketing of that food and
certainly at the westminster level
they've pressed pause on those childhood
obesity policies for at least another
year which in my mind is really madness
so you're saying the government has sat
on this question
you know of advertising and unhealthy
food for children yeah they absolutely
are sitting on it and the reason they're
sitting on and they're arguing that one
of it is the cost of living which is a
crisis the cost of living crisis we know
that
but the other the main reason for that
is lobbying it's industry lobbying
of course the food industry doesn't want
you to restrict the advertising they can
do on children's programs or on the
internet no absolutely they want to make
as much money as they can from people
eating products which are not beneficial
for our health and that's just the
reality and you'd be hard-pressed to
find many people who would disagree with
that as the main reason yeah and i think
this whole i completely agree james this
whole mantra of personal responsibility
is really really dangerous
because it's as if
um you know
the government the people we pay taxes
to haven't got responsibility and i
think one really stark example is is
children's classrooms you know it would
have cost
really so little in the scheme of things
to got decent ventilation in children's
classrooms and kept them safe it's never
been done and it's not enough to say
well teachers is your responsibility or
you know children it's your
responsibility so i think at the end of
the day if we want to change things and
if we want to ensure that there's better
health and well-being then actually i
think and again this is being political
maybe i don't know we need collective
action you know if we look why do we
have the things to debt that we have
today you know why do we have
the health service we have the education
etc etc is because people came together
and demanded it and collective action to
actually get things going i mean
remember the free school meals you know
there was campaigning for that um so i
think that's what we need to do going
forward and but that does empower people
it's a two-way thing you know if you're
together collectively you feel more
empowered to make a difference than if
you're just accepting the rhetoric well
it's up to to your personal
responsibility individual choice which i
think is really unhelpful james i can't
help but remember that the words modern
capitalism appear in the subtitle of
your book i mean you know have you got
to take a financial perhaps or a
political financial take on this
make us run away from the bigger picture
of the need for love housing
self-efficacy food classrooms
i mean is capitalism the dark hand
behind all this well well one of the
arguments i advance is that the reason
why the mental health sector has has
broadly in my view failed since the
1980s is because ultimately it's
developed as a social institution to
serve late capitalism rather than
individuals who are in in need and
that's the fundamental error at the
heart of the system
um but but picking up on on the point
about um where do we locate the cause of
of distress i think our mental health
sector broadly speaking has a lot to
answer for because i think we've sold a
model to the to the population over the
last few decades that
the cause of your problem resides in you
you know it's an internal dysfunction
right you've got a chemical imbalance
possibly by the way that's the myth it's
never been demonstrated that chemical
imbalance caused depression but anyway
that's a myth that was sold by the
pharmaceutical industry because if
you've got a chemical imbalance and the
drugs correct the balance they should
take the drugs it's a very popular myth
it got ssris off the ground but it's not
been
demonstrated or you've got a cognitive
dysfunction in between your ears
somewhere that needs to be resolved the
problem is when you work on the ground
with people you quickly learn but the
vast majority of people's distress is a
protest suffering is often in the
emotional realm of protest against
inhospitable and bad conditions it's a
call to change it's a signal that things
in your world aren't working it could be
a relationships it could be a family
life it could be a wider environment it
could be the unjust social structures to
which your subject inequality etc and so
forth and i think
going forward the mental health sector
if it has any hope of of reversing this
i think dire trending outcomes it has to
start acknowledging that that a lot of
the suffering we all experience isn't
rooted here it's rooted out there and so
we need to be focusing our intervention
because
it's an interaction you know it's not
one or the other it's an interaction you
can have the same people in the same
adverse circumstances and one does okay
and the other completely collapses so i
really think that you have to have a
model to understand people in relation
to the environment around them the other
thing is i also think there's an
interaction between um sometimes
medicines
and and the the help one gets from
medicines and one's ability to change
things in the world around to improve
things so i worked for many many years
as a clinical psychologist and i saw
many many people who were profoundly
depressed and yes some of them had had
very adverse experiences but whether or
not they had or hadn't
they were in a situation where
they were much they weren't in any
situation to be able to begin to help
themselves and to change things around
and to have those conversations and to
pick up the phone and all those other
things
and for many people
medication can make the difference
between them being completely helpless
and passive and actually having enough
sort of resilience and mental strength
to be able to do what's needed to help
themselves in the long run and then they
can come off them so you know they i
think they do have a role i'm i'm would
not be anti-medicines i think for mental
health as well as physical health i
think medicines have a role but i also
agree
like linda said about vested interests
the pharmaceutical industry especially
in the states and it's creeping in here
that you know that all of this should be
nationalized it shouldn't be
people who are going to make private
profit by making you think that you've
got this illness and therefore you need
that drug that's what the problem is i
think and not just big pharma i mean the
insurance companies in these days are a
huge uh understanding suffocator but all
three of you seem to be saying something
i think i just send a pattern here if
you know it's the bigger picture we have
to get to
you know all of these things biological
psychological social spiritual
how can you guys get the government
you've got there is after all to see the
bigger picture in their policies i think
you do it step by step i think we've
done it with smoking if you imagine the
1950s and 60s we had 80 of men who
smoked in the uk we exported
manufactured cigarettes to the world
and now we have the second lowest rates
of smoking in europe but it took 50
years
for the recommendations from the royal
college of physicians smoking and health
to be implemented so i think with some
of these other changes that we need to
make whether it's a better approach to
mental health dealing with some of these
preventable risk factors we have to take
it step by step because governments
rarely make big big changes the other
thing is two final points
we have to still stay standing so even
if you have an unpopular opinion keep
saying it
if there's good evidence behind it and
then also just train i think healthcare
professionals uh clinicians of a whole
variety of degrees to become political
because they actually see the case for
prevention and they see the case for
thinking about people's environments but
they're on the same track of
promotion thinking about the fact that
people want a prescription or need a
prescription
you know what what is their area of
expertise and they shouldn't stray out
of it so be political if you've got a
belief that's evidence-based keep
shouting about it and wait and wait for
your opportunity to make change because
i'm still hopeful that it will come
along
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas